celebrations for angela merkel's
historic third term electoral victory as
it was beamed to capitals across europe
no one expected such a decisive margin
41.5 percent for mrs merkel's christian
democrats and partners against the
opposition is 25.7 percent
um
it got mep's thinking and knew about
austerity and with elections for the
european parliament just eight months
off about their own electability
a very different line from the far left
in greece where austerity linked to
bailouts has been hardest felt and
there's talk of another bailout in the
pipeline
a more moderate line on a similar theme
from parliament's socialist group
germany needs a coalition and now it's
up to
mother america to counter decision but i
don't want to hide that for europe
participation of the spd would be very
beneficial
mother america has to think how she can
introduce also some social elements
europe's liberals were left reeling
after the vote because germany's
liberals the fdp failed to pass the five
percent threshold for a seat in the
bundestag liberals always suffer at
times of recessions and this is what's
happened here they are experienced
survivors i think they will be back but
concern in one camp was matched by
relief all over that the new anti-euro
party alternative for deutschland also
failed to pass the threshold if they had
that would really have shaken europe's
political boats